all right norman hey
how are you great how are you oh doing
really well
doing really well it's nice to hear so
what's the latest well the latest i went
back to work
uh reception was a tear
know because everybody clapped for me
and um
and they knew you know i actually let my
boss and my uh supervisor know
everyone knows your your story now yeah
they know
um what happened after uh the death of
my sister because i told him
i didn't want to be i don't want to hold
that back
i mean when you hold stuff back you know
you have a tendency to
just [ __ ] up you know and that would
have been a lie and i didn't want to
tell him a lie
and i told him you know and she was like
it's okay
she said to tell you the truth we kind
of expected it
because that's a very traumatic thing to
happen
and uh but we were behind you 110 so
that was pretty good
so we jump right back in um basically
they're gonna have to hire another
assistant manager
uh this guy he just couldn't take it he
couldn't take it it was
the paperwork was killing him but the
the honesty
yeah really helps you and helps everyone
else around you people are much more
forgiving and accepting than
yeah what do you expect them to be right
it's like when you told me somebody sit
on a stick around the corner
i was like huh i said well wait a minute
what's wrong you know i'm a test around
the corner now i have a childhood friend
that stays around the corner i'll come
down and i'll see you so you're i saw
you on skid row the other day
yeah yeah you know it's usually a sign
of trouble right right but no
nah not for me um um
i just take it a day at a time i don't
look too much far
in the future um i just try to stay in
here and now
do what needs to be done do what's ahead
of me
what did what you just went through with
your sister's death
teach you anything well you know
i don't one of my greatest fears is
death
and i believe it it stems from my mother
passing away and
me not believing that she was dead um
i'm thinking she's asleep in a casket i
had never been to a funeral
and um her body was in angela's funeral
home
and i remember my grandmother coming out
of that room crying and i remember my
sisters coming out of the room crying
and i went in there
and i closed the door and um
i remember looking at the casket and i
remember seeing her in there
i actually told her to wake up you know
when i felt her body it was stiff and
cold
you know
that's when i knew she was gone you know
how old were you 12. i mean this is uh
40 something years later you know
it's like it was yesterday
i mean you know i just
i miss my mother man
she was a fun loving person
she uh very outgoing
you know i know
one day i'm gonna die i don't want it to
be now
but i don't know when
but slowly but surely i'm becoming
honest with myself that it's gonna
happen
most importantly i'm looking at the fact
that goddamn and i don't have to make
self-induced you know
uh doing crack uh even trying that
crystal [ __ ] and
it's some people might say it's a slow
death but goddammit you don't know when
it might come
instantaneously you know maybe i could
take a hit
in my heart bust there's norman you know
another drug statistic
you know you know yeah i just don't um
i don't like it but i'm becoming i'm
coming to the mind frame of accepting it
because it's [ __ ] gonna happen you
know um
i can cry for my mom because i miss her
and it's okay you know just do um just
do the best that i can
you know just take it a day at a time
man i mean there's a lot of times where
like this week i think it was wednesday
i was sitting at the desk and it was
just
absolutely quiet
and i was just thinking hey man
dig deep and hunker down
listen when i got back to my hotel room
i have a journal i started
and uh the only thing i wrote for
wednesday was
dig deep and hunker down
because i you know regardless of what
people may think
about drug addiction it's a war
and it's a war that um
that i can't win but i can overcome
i look at it like that you know the
disease of addiction
is a very uh insidious
disease it tears everything up families
and
friends and the list goes on and on i
mean
you gotta
you gotta respect the disease and i
think more and more each day i'm
starting to respect it
um it's
it's something that um i wish i would
have never done but you know it's a
little bit too late for that
it's way too [ __ ] late you're talking
37 years
so
you know it's
there's a calmness inside of me that
i feel it and i look at it but i
i don't push it to the side but i'm like
okay
because see i felt this calmness inside
of me before
and quite frankly there was a part of me
that said okay
you got this but i don't want to put too
much
on myself do i say i got this
because how many times when i look at my
past have i said i got this
and the [ __ ] said i know i got
you it came and snapped
got me so
i was extremely focused
my first day at work and and i mean it
was just
they told me exactly what was going on
and i just hit it like the ground was
running man
i mean i was i was kicking some ass i'll
say that you know because i'm running
through uh
first time certifications which is a
hell of a lot of paperwork
i even surprised myself i knocked out 12
in one day
and um i always emailed my my uh
supervisor
and he went back all he said was wow
he said get him norman just keep getting
them
so we just we just keep
we just keep going man i don't
i don't know what the hell tomorrow's
gonna bring you know
i lost my damn phone no i didn't sell it
for the naysayers
i lost a [ __ ] phone and um
so i'm gonna get another one after this
interview and um
just keep going man i i see so much
i can see so much different stuff now
and i mean i look at it differently
you know there was a couple on the on
the bus i'd take the bus because
you know the cars you know yes i work
today and no i won't work
you know they were arguing
and this dude put his hand around this
girl's neck
and this other dude came in and he
socked that man so hard
and uh they called the sheriffs and all
that stuff we were off the bus
and asked her did she want to press
charges she said no
he said well ma'am
we can't do anything about it they were
right back
beside each other and i'm like okay
part of me saying okay she's stupid as
hell
the other part looked at
what i really seen her love for him is
powerful
regardless of what he's done
to hurt her nobody knows how many times
he's done this
but look how strong her love is for this
man who
was just physically abusing her
[Music]
so i really didn't give her too much
thought
that night i went home to the motel and
i couldn't sleep
gotta put some water on my face i think
i walked around the corner twice
and i came back and i left the lights
off
and what i heard was my love for you
is stronger than that
that for me was a propeller
you know because i think you've heard of
i had some god issues
before major ones
a lot of times i dissect [ __ ] too much
but i dissected this one
i mean i got up and i died i mean
i'm not supposed to go to work until
eight o'clock [ __ ]
i was up at four and i wrote in there
if his love is that strong for me
how will him or not how willing am i to
do what he wants me to do
and how strong will my love become for
him
that's all i wrote and i was like okay
and i think that that's what
it helped me through the week we didn't
have any problems i had one
guy he's vietnam vet he's uh
you know post-traumatic syndrome a lot
of stuff
and uh he had an episode
you know where he thought the vietcong
were after him and
stuff like that and
i calmed mr winston down because i just
looked at him i said mr winston
he's gonna be okay no no
he's just going i said mr winston
sir it's gonna be okay
he looked at me says okay mr norman
i'll go back to my room and he went back
to his room
i know you know you know i didn't call
the police i think his neighbor did
policemen looked at me he says hey man
that was a pretty good job
he said you didn't have to get loud or
anything he was just real calm he says
that was pretty good thank you i don't
you know you can give me some hats i
don't look at out of boys or pass on the
bank
you know my job is to help these guys
you know my job is to to to be a humble
servant
and do whatever the hell it takes to
alleviate conflicts
confusion i mean every day is not going
to be
if everybody said you know i've heard
this thing you know life is is a bed of
roses but goddammit have you ever looked
at the fact that they have thorns
so what does that mean they're going to
get pranked
you're gonna get pricked you're gonna
get stuck sometime like
like my relapse i got stuck
now if i haven't learned that the rose
has
have thorns on it then my dumb ass is
gonna go grab it again
and i'm gonna get stuck again so
as beautiful as they are i think i'll
let a professional cut the roses
instead of me trying to pick the roses
because every damn time i try to pick
them i get picked
and i'm tired of getting freaked you
know so you know
episodes that i have in life like that
i draw from them but i i i draw a little
more intently now
i look at it for exactly what it is but
i look at the god essence behind it
you know that was a point where god
instilled in me some calmness
and i think the latin term esparatus the
bringing out of
so it came out of me and it went to him
and he calmed down
and he said okay
no what can you say man you uh
you go through it in life humility is a
big part of it all
yeah there's a quote
well not as quote as the saying that
is running through my mind all [ __ ]
week and it's what
in the movie tombstone when doc holliday
was on his deathbed
and wyatt came to play some cards with
him and he says
he says doc all i've ever wanted was a
normal life
he says why there is no such thing as a
normal life
only life i'm like damn
and are we norman there's this
thing is a normal life it's only life
so of course my dissecting asset
dissected that and it said hey look
be you don't put too much on it
don't take anything away from it put it
in his hands
and ride live
life there's no normalcy to it i think
every [ __ ] body in the world has a
problem
whether it's drug addiction whatever it
is something something is going on so
just go ahead not so much grain and
barrier but deal with it
learn how to deal with it uh embrace it
because it's a part of you what's it's a
part of your story
you know so in the great book of life
you know
you can um you can pull that wherewithal
up because it's
it's coming i feel it i get the warm
fuzzies and i'm like okay
but i don't push it down but i'm like
okay no but i'm not
apprehensive and i'm not like okay this
is going over here okay no i don't do
that one
i just now i just okay
i just keep walking that's it
that's what i do excellent norman
great to see you looking so good well
great to be
seen at all and not hurt of um
one day at a time one second at a time
just just keep going excellent okay
all right man have a great weekend okay
that was great i'm trying the speaker
i'm probably one of the calmest
i've got some calmness